mr. Hancock a very good morning to you
we both know the drill by now short
questions short answers we'll get
through as much as we can in the time
allotted here we go from 9 o'clock this
morning two hours time if I get a knock
at the door from an NHS test and trace
advisor say I've had contact with
someone who tested positive for corona
virus must I self-isolation yes it's
really important that people who are
contacted by the NHS testing based
service from as you say 9 o'clock this
morning if you are instructed to isolate
then it's very important that you
isolate yes immediately yes immediately
because the reason is that that you will
have been in close contact with somebody
who's tested positive and so you're at
high risk what if I've got child care
issues well of course it's very
important that child care is taken into
account you know I understand that as
well as as anybody and so yes it's very
important that people deal with child
care and do that in a reasonable way but
I need to stay at home to and organize
child care issues yeah that is what you
will be instructed to do yes and you
should follow those instructions because
that's in the best interest of everybody
you understand why that might be an
issue for some people I think actually
the vast majority of people are going to
follow Watley and I just asked them to
do in these circumstances because it's
not only good for them it's also good
for their community it helps us all to
keep they are down the whole point of
this new system is to have a much more
targeted approach so that we can hold be
are down and get trace those new new
cases and then break the train of
transmission and that in turn means that
we can control the virus and we're safer
I understand at the same time lift other
elements of the law but you understand
that lots of people who are watching
will think that it's more real for them
one rule for us why should I do it if
people like Dominic Cummings don't do it
so I suppose what you might have to do
is Masek make it mandatory is that
something that you've considered well
yes we
have considered making this mandatory
and there are some other countries in
which it's mandatory but in the first
instance we have great faith that the
public will follow the instructions from
the NHS and my early conversations both
before we launched it and and since is
that the vast majority of people will do
as they are asked to do by the a that's
in the same way that if your doctor said
it's very important that you go home for
14 days then people would do that it's
that silly conversation yeah but how do
you make it Monday tree well there are
powers that we took through Parliament
that start of the crisis in the
coronavirus Act to be able to mandate
this but sorry I must push you on that
if I'm a health secretary how can you
possibly if you go to someone's house
and you say you've got to stay there
unless you're monitoring them 24/7 how
will you know how can you possibly
enforce that well it is of course all
these things are new and are a challenge
but it'd be far better if we didn't have
to make it mandatory so that's why we
one of the reasons that we've started
with it on a voluntary basis well I say
voluntary is in it's an instruction from
the NHS and it's very important that you
do it but it's legally not mandated at
this stage because we think is far
better far far better if as a country we
pull together and do this and everybody
who follows the instruction problem is
you've rushed it forward haven't you
because you want to take the headlines
away from Dominic Cummings so you
brought it forward it should have been
1st of June when the app is being
launched at the same time then with the
app what you could have done is if
people go out they have to have a GPS on
the phone and they have to get a call or
whatever a text every 6 or 7 hours like
they do in Singapore but you've had to
rush it forward it's priceless
ok I'm normally accused of delaying
these things and bring them in too
slowly we add I committed to getting the
system in in mid-may ok
didn't you health secretary and we still
not got that up
you said the app was absolutely
essential to this track and trace you
the app is still not ready until next
week at the earliest maybe after that
and yet you brought this forward I
suppose many of my viewers will think
it's not a laughing matter
yes well I can't quite work out whether
you're telling me that I've gone through
slow or too fast I think we've got it
just tell you what I was no I think
there is a confused as I am clarify it
for us yeah well we brought it in at
just the right speed and the crucial
thing with the app the app is helpful
it's working on the Isle of Wight but
there's a reason that we haven't brought
it in at this right at start which is
they yeah asking people to isolate even
if they're healthy because the NHS has
got in contact and informed them that
they're at high risk because they've
been in contact with somebody who's said
tested positive that is quite a big
chain and one of the things we learnt in
the pilot on the Isle of Wight is that
getting people used to that idea is
important to do before we then also add
the technological capability the app on
top and so you have to delay it but you
rushing in other parts of it rather than
launching it all properly together I
suppose is what my viewers might be
shouting at the screen this morning i I
doubt that many people will be shouting
and scream that I delayed it in one
question but anyway I'll try to I'll try
to answer it best I can
Tim the the pilot on the Isle of Wight
showed that the best thing to do was to
introduce the contact tracing the human
contact tracing and then build on that
once people have got used the idea that
when the NHS test entre system gets in
contact you've got to do quite a big
thing which is to isolate to week now
the the app adds value to this system
because it can help them to find
contacts who you simply wouldn't be able
to find any other way so you know if B
were on a bus say within two meters of
somebody you wouldn't know the
you were within two meters you wouldn't
know sorry you wouldn't know who they
were you wouldn't be able the app helps
as Baroness Harding who's running the
program said it puts the cherry on the
cake it isn't the cake okay
I'm glad we're clear about that I think
you have had coronavirus does that mean
that you don't have to self isolate no
the the science says that there is a
likelihood that those of us who've had
it have a lower risk but we are not yet
confident in that and we're currently
doing the research to find out if it's
true that those of us have had it can't
transmit it it's not only a matter of
those of us who've had it not getting
symptoms again it's very important that
we don't transmit it asymptomatic that's
okay what also might be not very amusing
for people is if they go on the London
tube or somewhere else where it's really
busy and then they get somebody at the
door saying you're going to have to self
isolate because you've been in touch
with in close proximity within two
meters of somebody who's had it you do
that for two weeks you go back to work
you get another call you do it for two
weeks you go back to work you get
another call that could happen it could
and that is part of life and who's gonna
pay who's gonna pay their wages when
that happens are you asking employers to
step in yes what if they don't well of
course there's a legal system around
that because you are legally equivalent
to being off ill and we brought that in
our sick pay as we know but would you
make that mandatory as well well yes the
employment law covers this and we
changed the law a couple of months ago
so that if you are instructed by the NHS
public health reasons to stay at home
then that's the equivalent in employment
law to being ill and it's very important
that employers are flexible around this
how quickly we're going to get these
test results back at the moment it looks
like it's several days the prime
minister said yesterday that he expects
it to be 24 hours he was pressed during
days on committee for how long before
that is the case he says he's been
forbidden to tell us
can't make anymore deadlines he's the
actual Prime Minister but he can't tell
us perhaps you can I can um 84% of the s
from the drive-thru centers are returned
within 24 hours 95 percent of all tests
are returned within 48 hours of course
there are examples of where the process
hasn't worked because this is now a
massive process and and there are so
there are individuals stray examples
we're working all the time to make it
faster I want to see every test returned
within 24 hours from those drive-thru
centers and we will do that just as
quickly as we can would brought down the
return after didn't tell us that
yesterday um well what he did was he set
me a goal of all tests from the
drive-thru centers being returned within
24 hours so his job is do is to set the
goals and my jobs to meet them okay he
said he can't set deadlines but there we
go what did you make of his performance
yesterday at the liaison committee well
I think he was very bare and solid and
the crucial thing yeah and the crucial
thing is that we we look forward to how
we can take the next stages the next
steps and take this country forward
and I think the large majority of what
he was talking about was about that okay
couple of questions before I let you go
no we're almost out of time um professor
which he and professor valence we saw
them arriving on Sunday and we were told
that they were going to do the news
conference at number 10 Downing Street
then they were in a little while then we
heard from mr. Cummings in the Rose
Garden and then they left and somebody
else did it we haven't seen them since
when are we going to see them at the
podium again
well I'm sure that they'll be at the
podium soon I mean they've both played
an absolutely advising the okay great
thanks for caring
Clara clearing that up forgive me
because there's been a lot of
speculation about that in the press but
we've heard it from you and of course
your you are the health secretary and
you've cleared that up thank you what
about what penny mordant and also Sajid
Javid two of your former colleagues one
still a colleague one a former colleague
at
saying one of them saying that it's time
for Dominic Cummings to go the other
ones saying that he should apologize why
they both wrong well I'm I don't agree
with them obviously on on this and what
really matters I think is that if we
take forward the next stage of how the
country can deal with coronavirus and
that's what the new NHS test and tray
system is all about having a more
targeted version of being able to target
who has to isolate rather than having
these blanket rules across all of us
which are having the enormous impact
that they are today I have to formally
review the rules on lockdown and you'll
be hearing later about the conclusions
of that we're doing everything we
possibly can to get this country back on
our feet and that is the absolute focus
of our attention you would give me
straight Alice that story started
talking about Dominic Cummings and then
we then we drift off it's about it's
about the future it's about the future
care and what we're doing to get this
yeah it's doing that but just to sum up
before we let you go from today you
could get a knock at the door
you have to self isolate for 14 days you
could go back to work come it could
happen multiple times its voluntary for
now if you don't it will become
mandatory we haven't decided when and
how that might happen at the app that
should go with this isn't quite ready
yet but it should be ready that is ready
we're choosing to bring it in later
clarifying just a key thing the key
thing would be everybody watching is one
if you have symptoms please go and get a
test and two if you test positive and if
the NHS then calls your contacts if you
get that contact from the NHS pest entre
system asked us to isolate two weeks
then it's very very important that you
do okay her Majesty behind you do you
think she'd approve I very much hope
that she would I think formally she
approves of everything that's done in
her name in her majesty's government and
we're all doing our best
indeed so it's good to talk to you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you